o
[Música]
boa tarde da tarde a todos vocês
é eu queria agradecer pelo convite
é de presumir que esse momento que é
muito importante estar aqui com vocês
para falar um pouquinho da minha
trajetória no mundo da música é eu
espero que vocês gostem do de todo esse
trabalho dessa trajetória não foi só uma
trajetória minha naturalmente né porque
ninguém faz nada sozinho
mas eu comecei é muito pequena já
decidida a ser música com cinco anos
você já podia me perguntar o que eu
queria ser e eu dizia que queria ser
pianista e por isso a palestra de um
sonho à realidade e esse sonho perdurou
praticamente toda a minha vida apesar de
ter mudado um pouco o curso daquilo que
eu imaginava daquilo que eu sonhava
eu fiz o meu curso no carlos gomes no
conservatório carlos gomes na época e
estudei casei
e segui a minha trajetória meu marido
junto comigo
nós fomos para os estados unidos e lá eu
tive oportunidade de estudar com grandes
professores de piano e toquei bastante e
no meu retorno eu fui convidada por com
o ex colega minha do conservatório pra
ir para a direcção do conservatório
isso na verdade eu não tinha programado
pra minha vida
na verdade é o meu sonho era tocar piano
mas de repente eu me vi guindada para
aquela escola onde eu me formei uma
escola que estava ligado à seduc
secretaria de educação que ela não tinha
autonomia administrativa financeira e
que é era muito difícil trabalhar
naquela situação que você precisava uma
folha de papel eu tinha que pedir para a
seduc ainda dependia da licitação que
eles tinham que fazer então foi um
momento bastante difíceis mas que eu
acabei imaginando muitas coisas que eu
acho que foram muito produtiva ao longo
da minha carreira administrativa lá
daquela minha escola
nós só tínhamos aula de piano
e eu achava que aquele aquele é um
instituto que praticamente tinha 100
anos de existência histórica porque foi
feito pra a vida do maestro carlos gomes
ele poderia ter muito mais um papel
muito mais importante dentro do estado e
daí começaram as idéias como fazer é
levar ao público o nosso trabalho aquilo
que era feito dentro das quatro paredes
e eu fui a o brigadeiro da aeronáutica e
pedir emprestado maestro de banda e esse
maestro veio de como voluntário trouxe
outros jovens que estavam espalhados por
aí tocando sax
enfim na série de instrumento e nós
fizemos uma boa banda de música e
começamos a apresentar o fora dos muros
do conservatório e aí começamos a fazer
uma propaganda da nossa escola
e usamos foram passando e eu tentava ver
se conseguia chegar aos políticos eu não
consigo não conhecia nenhum político nem
nada praticamente nada só dos jornais e
eu tinha um amigo que era diretor do
museu goeldi e que sempre você tem que
conhecer as pessoas para você conseguir
as coisas
e um dia o destino né
me colocou no mesmo avião do governador
o governador estava sentado na cadeira
na frente da minha cadeira quando o
avião decolou eu decolei também do meu
assento e fui à ao governador me
apresentei a ele disse que eu era
diretora do conservatório e que o
governo não não fazia uso de uma escola
tão importante era a única praticamente
a única escola de música que nós
tínhamos no estado e que ela tinha um
papel fundamental na educação e eu sabia
que o estado não tinha dinheiro mas que
podia tirar um pouquinho da do dinheiro
da propaganda que o estado faz o jogo do
meio de comunicação e colocar um
pouquinho na fundação se ele fizesse
isso nós devemos o retorno da mídia é
espontânea
bom isso foi outubro de 85 1985 e abril
de 86
eu recebi um telefonema do gabinete do
governador dizendo que ia fazer uma
visita
né é uma visita ao conservatório e que
eu colocar no papel tudo que eu quisesse
isso foram 77 horas da noite o
governador estaria às 9 horas da manhã
com isso ele veio ouvir ele fez a visita
geral ele veio com todo o secretariado e
daí eu vou ter que cortar um pouquinho
né
por causa do tempo e daí nasceu a
fundação carlos gomes para aqueles que
não não sabem como é que a fundação
carlos gomes nasceu ea partir daquele
momento nós passamos a ter uma dotação
orçamentária e passamos a ter um corpo
jurídico diferenciado o que facilitou
bastante a nossa vida e em seguida
também por força do destino eu fui à
manaus tocar e o regente lá é cláudio
santoro regente brasileiro conhecido mas
nascido em manaus e depois eu falei pra
ele que nós precisamos de professores e
ele disse que tinha uma ligação muito
grande com o leste europeu e que o custo
de trazer o músico seria muito mais
barato
então ele me passou o nome de quatro
professores de cordas e eu comecei de
que maneira nós podíamos trazer esses
professores eo museu goeldi ajudou muito
porque é o único caminho que tinha era
através do cnpq para poder conseguir ser
visto era muito difícil conseguir um
visto de trabalho é mesmo um estrangeiro
que viesse de da bulgária o ministério
do trabalho não permitir que esses
quatro professores vieram com passagem
da água pela antiga varig e foi o nosso
primeiro quatro professores de cordas
que nós tivemos no instituto que deu
origem à orquestra de câmara do pará
e hoje muitos desses alunos estão na
orquestra do theatro da paz é no ano
seguinte da vida desses professores nós
nós já começamos com o 1º festival
internacional que está até hoje
e esse festival internacional também
nasceu sensível ter pensado em fazer um
festival internacional foi apenas uma
coincidência de vários grupos que pedi
que me ligaram que gostariam de vir ao
brasil é pra se apresentar e eu consegui
juntar em uma semana o quarteto de
cordas de são paulo o quarteto de cordas
do missouri ou que o quarteto de cordas
da
da da holanda enfim e ainda nós já
tínhamos o quarteto de cordas da
bulgária que eram os nossos professores
e já orquestra de câmera e fizemos o
primeiro festival internacional sem um
centavo e as coisas foram crescendo né
aí trouxemos já o professor de percussão
que também nós não tínhamos depois
trouxemos um quinteto da tchecoslováquia
também para ser os nossos professores ea
coisa foi crescendo crescendo porque é
uma coisa muito importante que eu visava
era o mercado de trabalho
na verdade a minha inspiração foi
transformar uma escola de música e uma
empresa né
a empresa hipoteticamente né onde eu
tinha a os professores que eram nossas
máquinas onde nós tínhamos o nosso
resultado de trabalho que era o nosso
produto que eram os nossos músicos e
muitas vezes perguntava nós temos que
fazer a coisa é o que nós queremos nós
queremos que qualidade nós queremos
desse produto
então foi baseado nessa nessa inspiração
de uma empresa nem olhando o mercado de
trabalho é que as foram coisas foram
crescendo os nossos alunos foram fazendo
concurso para bandas militares diversas
bandas que já tinham tinham acabado como
a banda dos bombeiros
a banda dada
dada a prefeitura né da da polícia da
prefeitura a polícia militar também a
banda do dos dados do estado
então nós começamos colocar uma série de
músicos no mercado de trabalho o que
combinou naturalmente a área de cordas
com a orquestra do theatro da paz
posteriormente e em 95 né e eu consegui
nós conseguimos a criação do bacharelado
de música da fundação carlos gomes 95
foi assinada pelo pelo presidente da
república fernando henrique cardoso
autorizando que a fundação tannus gomes
é tivesse o seu curso de bacharelado em
fim e 96
eu saio da direção da superintendência e
o meu sucessor em planta a a fundação a
o bacharelado de música da fundação
carlos gomes
com isso alguns amigos me disseram por
que você não faz a sua própria fundação
e continua o seu trabalho e é isso que
se um item zinho também que foi feito o
projeto de interiorização e aí nasceu e
96 nasceu a fundação amazônica de música
que a que a que eu dirijo desde 96
aí realmente é foi um desafio muito
grande pra nós porque eu não tinha o
apoio financeiro do estado
eu tinha que em busca de algum recurso
pra contratar professores e o nosso
primeiro projeto foi lá no rancho
eu escolhi um bairro
um bairro que tem tido muitos problemas
sociais e consegui o espaço do rancho lá
no jurunas e começamos a atender 200
alunos
nós não tínhamos problemas de transporte
porque eles vinham a pé e e se esse
projeto deu muito fruto esse projeto
durou três anos e aqueles alunos que
eram mais talentosa e direcionava para o
carlos gomes ou para escola da
universidade bom mas comecei a perceber
um um projeto no projeto que eu pudesse
ficar mais tempo com esses alunos que
esse aluno nós trabalharmos sua voz e
percussão e flauta doce e foi assim que
a coisa também surgiu sem que eu pudesse
é vamos dizer ter premeditado ou alguma
coisa assim
um dia eu recebi um telefonema é do rio
de janeiro do presidente da fundação
vale é perguntando se eu podia atendendo
e
e que ele viria belém para conversar
comigo e ele propôs que fosse feito um
projeto com crianças de rede pública que
não soubessem nada de música né e que eu
fizesse uma orquestra sinfônica
então foi realmente acho que esse
momento foi o mais desafiador pra toda a
minha vida porque é uma coisa eu tinha
experiência já é do conservatório e eu
sabia que em cem alunos a gente tira um
músico então como é que eu podia fazer
uma orquestra sinfônica com 100 alunos
pra tirar 70 ou 60 foi o maior desafio
ele veio a belém e e aí começamos com
esse trabalho
esse trabalho de forma diferente de uma
escola formal porque os nossos alunos
tudo é feito na prática são crianças de
7 a 9 anos da rede pública de ensino e
que para eles chegarem aqui eles tinham
que ter vale transporte
eles tinham que ter lanche ele tinha que
ter a roupa eles tinham que ter um
instrumento e óbvio os seus professores
e nós conseguimos graças é é esse
convênio que foi feito com a vale
e hoje nós temos um resultado fantástico
muito acima daquilo que eu esperava
até porque era uma proposta totalmente
nova dentro ensino
nós não temos aulas teóricas separada
dado de instrumento né e hoje nós temos
uma orquestra sinfônica temos esse grupo
que vocês viram esse rapaz que hoje são
rapazes eles começaram conosco com 78
anos de idade né então o resultado isso
que vocês viram né e temos uma orquestra
sinfônica é temos um grupo de percussão
temos uma banda de música e hoje nós
temos cerca de 90 na universidade já
fazendo música
fora aqueles que foram para outras áreas
porque o projeto é dividido em três
etapas a primeira etapa que é a
socialização dessas crianças onde elas
aprendem a melhorar sua percepção a sua
concentração o seu ritmo
ela desenvolve isso isso vai ter um
vamos é uma rã uma repercussão muito
grande
é um resultado muito positivo na escola
porque o grande problema dos alunos é a
sua concentração que a criança com 15
minutos a concentração dele está já está
cansado e já não não tem mais
concentração ea música faz com que ele
ele melhore bastante essa concentração
de maneira que a segunda fase é a
adaptação instrumento ea terceira fase é
a orquestra onde ele recebe bolsa quando
a gente tem dinheiro é ele recebe uma
bolsa de 450 reais pra que é a fase da
profissionalização e ali eles vão é
aprender repertório de orquestra né
já vai também é ea estabilidade também
começa a pensar na universidade sirvam
para a música ou se vão para outras
áreas
enfim hoje praticamente nós temos 34
alunos de trabalhando na orquestra do
theatro da paz temos alunos nos estados
unidos temos alunos de são paulo
ian na na área
temos agora recentemente um aluno nosso
ele passou na orquestra daqui de manaus
na filarmônica de do amazonas
enfim é foi muito acima do que aquilo
tudo que eu sonhei um dia as coisas
foram acontecendo não foram programadas
eu nunca me programei para ser
professora de piano ou separar ou para
ser administradora de escola de escola
de música e mostrando pra vocês que as
coisas muitas vezes nós somos levados a
fazer alguma coisa e que nós devemos
aproveitar as oportunidades e os
momentos que nos são dados
e também dizer a vocês que na nossa
festa foi convidada a se apresentar em
julho na no teatro é na sala são pedro
uma das salas hoje mais festejado no
nosso país e nós deveremos seguir com 70
alunos que fazem parte da orquestra pra
o festival internacional de campos do
jordão é que eu precisar mais importante
do brasil não estamos nos apresentando
os lá e também na la em posso em campos
do jordão também na praça
então acho que isso é um resultado de
trabalho que eu trouxe pra vocês verem
essa trajetória é que eu tentei né
é com
é não dizer transformar praticamente uma
vida e 20 minutos
meu muito obrigado a todos vocês por
terem me escutado e eu acho que todos
nós devemos estar orgulhosos da nossa
dos nossos alunos da nossa gente e temos
que acreditar que o nosso jovem no nosso
jovem
nós temos o nosso futuro então obrigada
a tam